los aficionados a la música se dirigen
de nuevo al desierto de california
después de haber sido aplazado tres
veces debido a la pandemia coachella
está de vuelta a pesar del aumento de
los casos de coronavirus en todo el país
el festival no exige ni mascarillas ni
pruebas de vacunación ni un test cobit
negativo se espera que unos 125 mil
asistentes bailen toda la noche durante
dos o tres días mientras artistas que
actuarán se encuentra el grupo de rock
francés de imperatriz con su éxito a fue
top girls
sintética
y
[Música]
y el dj belga astro mike que actúa en el
festival del 2015 con kanye west
sin embargo webs no actuará este año
después de haber renunciado a su puesto
de cabeza de cartel el domingo a
principios de este mes west será
sustituido por the weekend y swedish
house mafia harry styles fue la cabeza
de cartel el viernes por la noche
estrenando una nueva canción y haciendo
un dúo con la invitada sorpresa shania
twain
la cantante estadounidense billy lis es
la principal atracción de la noche del
sábado